this is what you see in parts of
Zimbabwe's capital harar city council
workers often don't collect the garbage
then there is the raw sewage from burst
pipes that haven't been replaced in
decades this is kadana a lowincome high
density suburb we are going to do house
to house to teach them about cor and we
are teaching them about using the water
six teaspoon of so sugar half teaspoon
level salt in one liter in clean water
and then they drink before they come to
the clinic Health officials say the
colera outbreak is spreading almost
every sa has reported the case or we
have confirmed the case from almost
every Saab so but those are still
sporadic the main ones are now at
kuana in 2008 thousands of people died
from colera here this latest outbreak
has people worried the government wants
to ban Street vendors from selling food
but that may not be easy to do
Zimbabwe's unemployment rate is high
selling on the street is how many people
make in meat authorities say there isn't
enough money to provide clean water and
upgrade aging equipment and
Facilities health workers are trying to
help those who are sick but there is a
shortage of drugs at public hospitals as
cases rise zimbabweans have been told to
be extra
vigilant
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jaaz